so einfach und schnell könnt ihr
fluffige pancakes selber machen und das
ganze ohne viel schnickschnack zuerst
werden milch eier zucker und vanille
extrakt in einer schüssel miteinander
verrührt jetzt kommen mehl und
backpulver mit dazu und das ganze wird
auch noch mal schön verrührt ihr müsst
ihr zutaten darf übrigens nicht 7 sobald
ihr eine richtig schöne homogene masse
habt kommt noch zerlassene butter mit
dazu jetzt die pancakes in einer
beschichteten pfanne von beiden seiten
aus packen sie brauchen ungefähr
eineinhalb minuten pro seite und wenn
ihr eine gut beschichtete pfanne habt
dann braucht ihr kein zusätzliches fett
ich lasse mir noch mit haselnuss creme
und schokocreme schmecken und wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß ihm nachmachen die
genauen mengenangaben schreibe ich euch
unten in die kommentare falls sie meine
rezepte nicht verpassen möchte dann
macht jetzt auf jeden fall ein abo da
und sei beim nächsten video auch wieder
mit dabei